♪ [upbeat music plays]
Matt Trifino: Assistly turns customer
service into customer wow.
It allows you to manage all your
communications with your customers.
All-in-one customer service solution
for companies that wanna deliver service
across email, self-service,
frequently asked questions,
web, Twitter, Facebook, Live Chat.
All the channels that you might
wanna connect with your customers.
So, we target small- to medium-sized
enterprises who are customer-driven,
wanna get close to the customers,
wanna deliver customer service at scale.
They have a lot of customers.
Their inboxes are overflowing.
And they need a way to deliver
great customer service,
'cause that's differentiated
for them in their business.
So we provide a tool set
that optimizes those workflows,
allows your entire company to collaborate
on delivering support to those customers
and tracks every customer interaction
in an air-tight case management system.
So when every case comes in,
it's got assigned a ticket.
It's got a status.
It's got an owner.
So nothing ever falls through the cracks.
So, we're a business-to-business application.
We sell to businesses.
And so what Google has done is
they've done all the heavy lifting.
They've convinced these organizations
to adopt a cloud as a hundred percent web.
Put your entire business on the web.
And so, it's a great synergy.
The companies that have already
adopted Google Apps,
they've made that decision to use it
in their business
and now they're looking for ways
to leverage that investment.
00:01:18.667,00:00:00.000